and tonight shocking footage coming out
of los angeles overnight where comedian
dave chappelle was attacked on stage
during a performance at the hollywood
bowl now video shows a man rushing onto
the stage tackling chappelle before
being surrounded by security and being
detained now the 23 year old assailant
was reportedly carrying a replica gun
with a knife blade inside it and he has
now been charged with assault with a
deadly weapon now chappella's okay he
even joked about the attack right after
it happened a spokesperson for chappelle
tells fox news that he is fully
cooperating with police as they
investigate what they call an
unfortunate and unsettling incident but
footage from outside uh the incident
shows the attacker being carried away on
a stretcher with a pretty serious
looking arm injury now chris rocky you
know of course the slap hurt around the
world he was also in attendance last
night apparently joked about the
incident asking was that will smith all
right here with reaction the host of
piers morgan uncensored which by the way
airs uh new episodes four times a week
when you go to foxnation.com
all right across the pond we'd love to
see our friend pierce
look when i watched the slap
just watched around the scene around the
world uh with will smith
a part of me was like okay
uh if you're that sensitive why don't
you talk it out it was an overreaction
now we see this attack against chappelle
i happen to think chris rock dave
chappelle larry the cable guy every
irreverent
comedian i love those guys
why are people reacting this way to
jokes
well i think uh sean it's a natural
extension of what you see all day long
on twitter and other social media
platforms where you have this canceled
culture mob running around who think
that only their view about issues is
acceptable and anyone that differs from
that view has to be shamed abused
punished cancelled and now we're seeing
this manifesting itself in physical
violence and it's it's a very sinister
development this if comedians
can't tell irreverent jokes on stage
without a fear of being smashed in the
face or worse this guy had a weapon that
could have killed dave chappelle then
where does that take it what does it
take freedom of speech freedom of
expression where does it take comedy uh
so i think it's all very unsettling and
a direct consequence of what we saw at
the oscars where i was a bit like you i
was kind of in a way it was like a scene
out of a bar and brawl between one guy
this is another guy's wife and it ends
up with a slap uh but now i kind of
think you know actually i said a very
bad precedent
and the president is now being
replicated and i think if i was a
comedian right now like chappelle like
these guys with a big following in front
of big audiences you've got to be
walking on stage now particularly if
chris rocks anywhere near you and
worrying about where the next punch is
coming from
you know you talked about cancel culture
so i've been doing radio 35 years i've
been on fox's you know 26 and a half
years in all my time on the air i have
never called for any person to be fired
any show to be canceled any show to be
boycotted
one thing people seem to forget is
audiences they have a choice they don't
have to listen to a radio show they
don't have to watch a tv show they don't
have to go to a comedy show here what
part of freedom in all of this
are people missing because when i go to
a if i'm going to watch a comedian
i want no holds barred say anything you
want and if you don't if you're going to
be so easily offended stay home i'm not
offended chappelle is funny he's
irreverent he's politically incorrect i
think he's one of the best comedians out
there along with chris rock
oh and also yeah and also i think what
is also unsettling is that he's come
under a lot of fired dave chappelle for
some netflix specials where he addresses
this whole issue of transgenderism in
america and he raises some really
interesting points about it about the
you know inequality for example in sport
and psalms that's
arising out of these issues these should
be debated in a free democratic society
like the united states and you should
better have a vigorous debate about it
and argue and reach points of consensus
but that's not allowed so dave chappelle
made some jokes about the transgender
community i didn't think they were
transphobic i think he was just having
fun as he did as he does with everybody
but in return for that he got death
threats he had threats against his
family he had to up his security and now
we see him being attacked on stage and
you know it comes back to what i've said
about this new council culture is in a
way it's a form of the very fascism that
these so-called liberals who who profess
to to be woke it's it's a very form of
fascism they they say they hate most in
life so they're going around trying to
dictate what we can find acceptable what
is funny what we're supposed to allow to
watch on television or movies you know
what statues we can reveal what
historical figures we can respect and so
on and if you don't toe the line now
they're going to use violence to make
you do it that is fascism and it
shouldn't be happening in
in modern day america or britain or
anywhere else it's a so-called democracy
i'm proud of the fact i can tell you in
all the years i've been in media not
once
have i ever been to the white house
correspondents dinner my record stands i
didn't show up this year apparently
turned out to be a super spreader event
anyway so i'm glad i didn't go
but i've never been there once so i've
never in my entire life
thought that trevor noah was funny now i
watched the show it seemed like every
other comedian late night comedian it's
just too liberal it's always one-sided
but i noticed i watched some clips after
he went after fox news cnn fake news cnn
cnn plus he went after republicans he
went after democrats he went after trump
he went after biden he went after
everybody and i said wow for the first
time
he's funny
um
why do these why are these late nights
why these late night comedians take it
on a political agenda sorry go ahead why
is it well i think i i think the point
about if i got trevor no i thought he
made a very good point should i say
you're concerned about him over the
years but actually i thought he did a
very good job that night because he made
this point that when you see what's
happening in ukraine when you see what
happens in russia in china and north
korea in totalitarian regimes when you
see all this going on it's really about
cancelling people's right to free speech
and expression and when he turned to joe
biden and said no i'm allowed to insult
the president of the united states
sitting a few feet away from him that
was a powerful moment where i think
everyone in america and around the world
should look at that moment and reflect
then on what happened with dave
chappelle how can it be that trevor noah
is allowed to do what he did at the
white house correspondents dinner
and that is free speech at its best and
how at the same time are you seeing
people attacking comedians for making
jokes because they don't think they're
entitled to make that joke without
getting violence against them that's the
that's what's happening more it's scary
somebody's going to get hurt
this guy could have killed him and then
dave chappelle if he'd been shot dead or
stabbed to death by this guy he could
have been either if we didn't know it
could have been really bad until after
the event right i want to go back too
imagine that moment where a comedian is
killed for comedy that would have been a
terrible moment we need more of the
moments like trevor noah mocking the
president sitting a few feet away from
him and we need a lot less tolerance of
what went on with dave chappelle
one thing i want uh we only have about a
minute left
we spoke last time when you had walked
off good morning britain the number one
morning show now it's in the tank
without you which
that should make you really proud um but
we talked about
meghan markle and ofcom and most
americans don't know what ofcom is but i
think they're going to know pretty soon
you've heard about this this department
of homeland security proposal of a
ministry of truth or
against disinformation uh we're going to
have the government decide that how bad
did it get in britain because i it might
be a preview of coming attractions here
well i just think it's it's to me the
principle of having a
government-appointed body to regulate
free speech is just wrong
and i think it i never believed in it
here i don't know why we accept it here
frankly but we we do uh but in america
in particular with the first amendment
you've got to tell me really the
department of homeland security is going
to dictate free speech the american
people and by the way representing a
democrat government right now with a
democrat president where in the last few
years alone i've watched as they've
peddled you know the russia collusion
nonsense uh i've watched the hunter
biden laptop scandal being suppressed
and so on is that is that their idea of
free speech because if the people who
did that are now going to dictate to the
american people what free speech is
that's a really concerning moment and it
shouldn't be happening the american
people should be free to express
themselves in any way they see fit and
if the government really is serious
about disinformation well look in your
own backyard and stop peddling your own
disinformation and that applies in
america it applies here in britain you
know my message to oftop regulate the
government on some of the stuff they
come out with
all right pierce love having you thank
you sir great to talk to you all the
best hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else